you can subscribe to the spectator for
12 weeks for only 12 pounds
for our print and online editions plus
get six months of digital access free to
the telegraph
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash telegraph
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
every week a few of our magazine writers
read out their pieces from the new issue
this week we're going to be joined by
jeff finpal a historian who debunks what
he calls the myth of the american stolen
land
i.e how the european colonialists came
to have the continent
we're also going to be joined by
christopher snowden from the institute
for economic affairs
who takes a look at the true cost of
coronavirus on the economy
and at the very end a notebook from joe
deakin who writes about the situation of
coronavirus in her home country of
madagascar
it's not her real name because of the
sensitivities of the topic
first jeff vin paul last month
in the middle of the coved panic a group
of first-year university students
at the university of connecticut were
welcomed to their campus via a series of
online events
at one event students were directed to
download an app for their phones
the app allowed students to input their
home address and it would piously inform
them from which group of native
americans
their home had been stolen
we all know the interpretation of
history on which this app is based
the united states was founded by a
monumental act of genocide
accompanied by larceny on the grandest
scale
animated by racism and a sense of
civilizational superiority
columbus and his ilk sailed to the new
world
they exterminated whoever they could
enslaved the rest
and intentionally spread smallpox in
hopes of solving the native question
soon afterwards they began importing
slave labor from africa
they then built the world's richest
country out of a combination of stolen
land
wanton environmental destruction and
african slave labor
this stolen country paradigm is now
dominant in our culture
the bbc's recent piece on the 400th
anniversary of the plymouth landing
takes obvious delight in portraying the
pilgrim fathers as native mutilating
slave drivers
in the greater toronto school district
students are read a statement of apology
acknowledging european guilt for the
appropriation of first nations lands
before the national anthem is played
over the pa system
every morning it is of course necessary
to challenge smug feel-good
interpretations of our history
nationalism and civilizational pride
carry obvious dangers which were made
manifest by the world wars
but it is also true that if the pendulum
of interpretation swings too far in any
one direction
things can rapidly go from bad to worse
so what can be the harm in acknowledging
every morning that canadians live on
stolen first nations land
the problem is this if you begin the day
by acknowledging that your country your
society and people of your ancestry are
particularly egregious
this is a sure route to societal
self-doubt impotence and failure
democracies thrive or fail on the basis
of national stories this is doubly so in
republics like the us where there is no
apolitical figurehead to unite people in
place of a monarch
as history shows time and again as soon
as a republic does not believe in itself
and its ideals
that it's better than the tyrannies and
autocracy surrounding it
it succumbs very quickly to autocracy
the recent riots across the u.s
attest to the breakdown of the western
democratic order which is being spurred
by these self-inflicted wounds
we must bring balance back to our
interpretations
history was invented by the greeks as a
science its nobless purpose
is to discredit those who would use
myths to justify
hatred ignorance and depression at the
present moment
it's the left with their canceled
culture who are most guilty
of these crimes against history the myth
of the stolen country or native american
genocide does not stand up to scrutiny
by any honest and clear-sighted
historian
first no matter who discovered the new
world it's inevitable that a large
proportion of new world inhabitants
would have died within the first few
decades after first contact
this is universally acknowledged by
specialists in the field
the new world population was smaller and
more homogeneous than the old world
population
so its people had less immunity to
disease than the people of the old world
where disease communities from africa
asia and europe had been
intermingling for millennia even though
some european captains did try to spread
smallpox around a few forts and villages
from time to time
the effect of their efforts was almost
negligible
compared with the natural spread of
disease old world rice and wheat
agriculture could support
high population densities per hectare
and the huge disparity in population
density between the old world and the
new
therefore made it likely that excess
population was going to flow from the
old world to the new
furthermore as soon as old world
colonists began to set up the farming
and city-dwelling societies which they
imported from home
population growth in the colonies was
bound to outstrip
that of native american groups low
population devastated by disease is
therefore the main explanation for why
british north america was so thoroughly
europeanized when many other parts of
the globe were not
in fact the europeans were surprisingly
ungenocidal
given their clear technological
advantages over the rest of the world
for a period of several centuries
the truth is that few other
civilizations given similar power over
so much of the world's people would have
behaved in a less reprehensible manner
this is not to give europeans a pat on
the back
rather it is to point out that europeans
are regularly painted
as the very worst society on earth when
in fact they had
the power to do far far more evil than
they actually did
rather it is to point out that europeans
are regularly painted as the very worst
society on earth when in fact they had
the power to do far more evil than they
actually did
let us also acknowledge that native
american society was
just as warlike as any other in human
history
the anthropologist's vision of native
americans as peace pipe smoking
environmentalists
which gained purchase in the 1970s has
long since given way to a more habesian
portrait of pre-columbian reality
in north america most natives with some
exceptions
had no permanent settlements they farmed
in an area for a few decades until the
soil got tired
before moving on to greener pastures
this meant the tribes were in constant
conflict with other tribes
it also meant the chiefs were
continually vying for power
creating confederations under themselves
and that the question of to whom the
land belonged was
in a more or less constant state of flux
meanwhile some groups of natives
slaughtered bullied or enslaved others
should we not be grieving for those
native canadians whose land was stolen
by other
native canadians or is that somehow okay
i don't suppose there's an app for that
should we not be grieving for those
native canadians whose land was stolen
by other native canadians
or is that somehow okay i don't suppose
there's an app for that
another major issue is this what
precisely would our
pious anthropology professors have had
the europeans do with the new world once
they found it
this is not a joke political reality has
a way of crashing in on the pipe dreams
of liberal academics
if the english had not colonized then
the french or the dutch would have
if the spanish had not colonized the
portuguese would have
the only reason that the arabs and
chinese did not colonize the new world
after its discovery
is because they did not at that moment
have quite the shipbuilding or
navigational expertise
even though they were fully capable of
sailing thousands of miles around the
indian ocean
another accusation leveled against
europeans is that they
quote destroyed native culture but let's
look for a moment at how cultural
contact actually works
the simple fact is that when a good idea
comes along which clearly increases
living standards
people tend to adopt it and who is to
say that such
adaptation is bad native americans were
quick to adapt many useful old world
ideas which europeans had brought with
them
most of these had been adopted by
europeans from other old world cultures
why grind corn laboriously by hand for
several hours a day
when you can use millstones instead why
hunt with a bow and arrow when you can
use a rifle
why not domesticate cattle why refuse to
adopt the wheel for goodness sake
by the time columbus sets sail the old
world had dozens of clear technological
and institutional advantages which for
the most part
new world populations were eager to
adopt this made it inevitable that new
world society would be changed
once sustained contact was initiated
there is therefore little real mystery
of what happened to the native americans
as a culture
they were not exterminated at the behest
of any concerted
ideology of hatred or european
superiority
after the initial epidemics and in spite
of a few sensational wars and
small-scale massacres
remaining native americans adopted so
many old world customs
that most were gradually assimilated
into a new culture
this culture was mostly european in
british north america
but it was much more hybrid in places
like mexico and peru
where indigenous population density was
highest
many native americans converted to
christianity and took up farming
hundreds of thousands intermarried
further attesting to the ability of
average people of both
quote races to get along despite the
prejudices of pre-modern society
only a small proportion of native
americans stayed wild enough to be
placed on reservations
even then many people later left for a
better life elsewhere
this was done on an individual basis for
the most part
peacefully and willingly and yet the
one-sided stolen country narrative
continues to gather steam
fueled by a tiny minority of activists
bent on bringing maximum embarrassment
to capitalism
democracy western civilization and
europeans in general
the only reason for them to be so
unreasonably angry about things that
happened centuries ago
is because they see everything through
the lens of perpetual racism and
victimization
and crucially because they do not
believe in the power of democracy
to correct these wrongs marxists and
their sympathizers have always believed
that creating a
good society is best left to a handful
of self-appointed intellectuals than to
the rough and tumble of parliamentary
debate
has history taught them nothing the ones
who will really lose out if anglophone
democracy is further discredited
are surely those people in the world who
are most vulnerable
it is high time historians spoke out
against the dangerous misuse of history
which supports the zealotry and
iconoclasm currently emanating from our
educational systems
this has become far too culturally
dominant far too damaging to global
society
for us to ignore it any further that was
jeff finpal
and now christopher snowden when future
historians look back on the 21st century
mortality statistics
they will struggle to find anything out
of the ordinary in britain in 2020
when they look at the economic data they
could be forgiven for thinking we were
hit by an asteroid
the office for budget responsibility
predicts a fall in gdp
of around 12 percent in 2020 the
equivalent of having the 2008
recession twice in one year the second
quarter saw gdp fall
by 20.4 breaking the record set during
the great frost of 1709.
the economy rallied by 6.6 percent in
july
which sounds impressive until you
consider that it only took the economy
back to where it was in the spring of
2013.
the full impacts on unemployment won't
be known before the furlough scheme ends
but the obr expects it to treble to over
4 million
the highest number since the 1930s the
furlough scheme costs 35 billion pounds
and is one of the many reasons why the
public finances are in such a wretched
state
in july total government debt passed a 2
trillion pound mark for the first time
the national debt has doubled since
austerity began in 2010
and now amounts to 104 percent of gdp
a level not seen since the immediate
aftermath of the second world war
at the start of the year the obr
expected public sector net borrowing to
be 55 billion pounds
it is now forecast to be 322 billion
public spending is predicted to rise by
182 billion while tax receipts fall by
130 billion
nearly every form of tax is bringing in
smaller revenues
it is no surprise that fuel alcohol and
air passenger duties have dwindled
but the government is also expected to
get 21 billion pound less incorporation
tax and
originally forecast 23 billion less in
income tax
7 billion less in stamp duty and 11
billion less in business rates
these are only forecasts but it's worth
noting that each of the obr's four
predictions since march
has been more pessimistic than the last
a second lockdown would be catastrophic
beyond words
take the damage done by the first lock
down and approximately double it
in some ways it could be less severe it
might be shorter
in many respects however it would be
worse because it will deliver the coup
de gras to businesses that are already
on the brink
how many shops pubs restaurants and gyms
will get through the winter without
customers
how long can lower league football clubs
play games in empty stadiums before they
go bust
whole industries would be hung out to
dry at the start of lockdown many
commentators myself included
were reasonably sanguine about the
spiking government borrowing the
circumstances were exceptional and the
borrowing was a one-off
the jobs and businesses being protected
were viable in normal times
and it made sense to mothball them
rather than allow them to go to the wall
the rise in borrowing was temporary not
structural
and there was reason to think the
economy would return to something like
normality in 2021.
people having money to spend but nowhere
to spend it is a better problem to have
than people having no money to spend
a recession was inevitable but there
were hopes that it would be v-shaped
as businesses reopened and shoppers made
up for last time
that optimism began to wither when a
three-week lockdown to save the nhs
became a six-week lockdown to flatten
the curve and then a 12-week lockdown to
what eliminate the virus prevent death
at any cost
flatten the economy if there has been a
strategy since may
it has never been articulated if i had
to guess i would say that the plan is to
ensure that boris johnson is never again
accused of acting too slowly
only a sucker would fall for the idea
that next lockdown will be a mere
circuit breaker
lasting a fortnight supporters of
lockdown are adept at switching between
cases and deaths depending on which is
rising
deaths lag behind cases by three weeks
so even if a two-week circuit breaker
reduced transmission
the number of deaths would still be
rising by the end of it
with the likes of piers morgan howling
from the sidelines
and the zero covered fantasists
re-energized
it is hard to imagine the government
ending lockdown with the death rate
climbing you can almost hear the slogan
now
one last push to save christmas and when
case numbers rise again in the new year
as they will
who will resist a third lockdown
especially with the promise of mass
vaccination just around the corner
all the while the money printer will be
worrying
according to the economist the central
banks of britain the eurozone japan and
the usa
have created which is to say printed 3.7
trillion dollars this year
if this does not lead to inflation the
economics textbooks will need rewriting
higher inflation means higher interest
rates and suddenly the cheap money being
borrowed won't be so cheap
in the long run britain can withstand
bungling politicians shaking the magic
money tree
historic levels of debt and employment
won't finish us but the overreaction to
covert 19 will leave scars that define
the decade
future generations will be bewildered
that a prosperous country
threw its economy off a cliff in a
failed attempt to suppress a disease
that kills less than one percent of
those infected most of them
in their 80s and 90s they will have
every reason to wander
since they will be the ones paying off
the debt or more likely
paying the interest on the debt the
mounting financial cost is easy enough
to measure
but the true cost goes much further than
that how strange are people who believe
the dubious factoid about 130 000 people
dying of austerity
see no negative health consequences from
this economic self-immolation
the scale of the disaster is so numbing
that even the prospect of a no deal
brexit
barely registers as a problem anymore
unless the government develops a
backbone
the 2020s will make the lost decade of
the 2010s
look like a golden age that was
christopher snowden
and now joe deacon writing under the
pseudonym earlier this month
in his weekly address to the nation our
president
the former dj and coup leader
andre rajalina announced that madagascar
would shortly produce an injectable
treatment for covert
a medicinal cure not just for madagascar
but for the world this was no great
surprise to the people of madagascar
after all way back in april when clover
had barely hit
our beautifully remote island president
andre
launched covered organics a miracle
drink
that serves both as a prophylactic
and a cure to the virus sweeping the
world covered organic
also known as cvo is based on a herbal
remedy for malaria
artemisia and nua along with extracts
from other
local plants while madagascar has a
wealth of endemic plant species many of
which have healing properties that
remain
underexploited artemisia was in fact
imported from china and now the drink is
being manufactured
in factories hastily erected with
foreign investment
for many months president andre has
extolled the benefits of his elixir
as the number of infections rose the
president confidently
assured us that this was simply because
not enough people were drinking it
after the first deaths he said the same
then later as the death toll mounted he
changed his tune to say that the real
problem
was that people weren't drinking enough
cvo in july
when deaths reached triple figures those
of us lucky enough to have television
sets
and electricity watched as the president
and his wife plugged down
cvo on camera as if it were lemonade
smiling throughout
in spite of its notoriously bitter taste
while the world health organization
rings its hands about the lack of
clinical trials madagascar is bravely
forging ahead
to date 20 african countries have
received
shipments of cvo in its drinkable liquid
form
which has been marketed as an african
solution
for africa individuals anywhere in the
world can bite direct
over the internet in madagascar a bottle
of cvo
costs 40 pence in the local supermarket
online it retails for a hundred dollars
plus shipping perhaps the president
thinks of it not as a cure for the virus
but for the economy economic stimulation
is definitely much needed
for most people life is hard in
madagascar
famines occur so regularly that there is
even a season for them
and the efforts to constrain the
coronavirus have worsened
an already difficult situation
like many other countries madagascar has
gone into lockdown
people rushed to make it home before
curfew
their face masts dangling around their
chins
children play together in the dust
outside of the locked school gates
the hotels and restaurants are empty
swimming pools drained health
checkpoints have been set up by the side
of
the road and people jostle each other as
they wait in line for a temperature to
be taken
before entering town in the developing
world
a cut in income quickly translates
into increased malnutrition inability to
pay for basic medicine
and death from starvation or entirely
treatable illness
so far just over 200 people have died
from covered in madagascar
a country with a population of 27
million
the lives lost due to the indirect
impacts of covert
from famine decreased vaccinations and
medical care
are likely to be orders of magnitude
greater
i was recently telling my youngest son
the story of hansel
and gretel and the wicked stepmother who
led them away to die
in the forest that they could not afford
to feed them anymore
there's nothing allegorical about this
tale to a madagascar
it is something we see daily a malagasy
friend
developed a fever which refused to go
away
eventually he stumped up the money for a
doctor
it's all fine he said happily when you
saw him later it's not covered after all
it's only typhoid fever since march
three people we know have died
two are food poisoning and one of
dysentery
hygiene levels are lethally low here
diarrhea and dysentery kill as do
infectious diseases like tuberculosis
measles malaria hepatitis
and plague bubonic and mnemonic
meanwhile international aid has been
diverted from vaccination programs
food aid and basic health and sanitation
work
to fund the fight against covered
this has been done with no analysis of
the relative costs and benefits it has
been blithely assumed
that covid represents a greater risk to
this generally
youthful population than other fatal
communicable diseases the cycle ritual
drivers
at the bottom of our street who live a
hand-to-mouth existence in any case
are muttering about rioting
with tourists gone their usual clients
the cleaners and the righteous and the
food suppliers who served the tourists
no longer have the spare change for a
rickshaw ride into town
their union has declared that there will
be a riot
if there is further lockdown
the government has threatened to send in
troops
from the capital to quell any rebellion
bring it on the ritual drivers replied
better to die fighting in the streets
than to starve to death in our homes
that was
joe deacon thanks for listening to this
episode of spectator out loud and do
join us again next week